è il nostro momento
mia madre è da circa 5 o 6 anni che mi
dice perché non fai un po di sport che
sei magro come un chiodo ho deciso oggi
di dare ascolto a mia madre mamma guarda
come tuo figlio fa lo sport quello vero
cazzo bello e tutti i ragazzi dove sono
io sono famiglie che siamo su step1
esterni che ci che vengano ragazzi è
veramente un gioco che simula una parte
devi stare carlo devi stare gatti devi
stare calmo le uova life è propriamente
ragazzi un gioco che simula gli sport
estremi
ok il prossimo la nipote estremi quindi
quelle cose che fai che che faccio io di
solito la martina vedi io che sono
esperto di sport estremi per me fare
questo video sarà un giochetto insomma
infatti mandato raggiungere dato sono
vivo
non so fare visti gli occhi e ti può
andare dritto altro elemento bene puoi
usare le gambe frate cui camminare
volendo anche no non camminano rinuncia
le gambe torino a posto rosa il binocolo
che cazzo ne faccia del binocolo ma non
posso più andare avanti stai fermo sta
premendo europeo ma penati [ __ ] ma
cos'è basata sul fermo donne cosa e
vabbè io no niente frate say die dei
problemi se tu stessi fermo fermo
basta o se stai fermo un attimo e
riescono usare o mite ci ho messo un ora
sta bene
stai fermo ora ragazzi che questo era lo
snowboard una delle tante cose che posso
fare però di base in teoria posso fare
un botto di cose tipo questa che rimette
ci sono un sacco di sport questa la tuta
alare io che
sono pratico di tute alari bene al frate
se prima stava rischiando di morire
adesso sei praticamente già morto
c'era poco concentrato il burro frasi
che non dirò mai più in tutta la mia
vita però ok se lo faremo lo fare aiuto
come sia a terra che come faccio ad
atterrare in area capelli porca [ __ ] il
ponte no vabbè non ci credo lo so cosa
ho fatto
conso fatto come ho fatto a passare
sotto il ponte un genio uno che si butta
normalmente a terra
voglio andar milan la giornata si è una
bella giornata
se io per caldo volessi atterrare san
salvo posso fai vai zio vai di ovaio
velio carico ti voglio carico schiva le
montagne manco goku va bene ok bene
sono ancora vivo non so che c'è una
linga festivo
no fermi ragazzo deve andare sulla diga
posso andare sulla diga di mala di
grande aiuto come fa aiuto
tu sei fashion con la tuta alare che
cammini quanto è bella sei un incendio
alla ragazzi per arrivare alla diga
perché credo che la diga si possa fare
qualcosa di figo non ne sono sicuro ma
credo di si lesse glee crs ok
buongiorno sono lavori ghiaccio ci posso
andare con snow board non è vero non è
vero mai non è vero non ci credo ma che
figata è fermati ferma di certo non mi
fermo
ragazzi ho perso tutta la diga non so
dove siano perso proprio a questa non è
ancora fatta dai prova a far questo non
so che quel coso a bicchiere questa roba
qui terne selvatiche stai calmo stavo
leggendo
nel di strato bip frante scusami ma
distratto c'era un big sono giustificato
scusa allora no data la parte opposta di
reputare sei scemo calmati dalla tab
aperte per questo 2000 era tanto
difficile bene allora chi cazzo è quello
che chiedo cosa è successo piccione
morto il nuovo piccione l'articolo
ma è online sto gioco non ho capito che
chi era quello la versioen mi sa che il
tipo che devo seguire per fare ok cupid
pronti dovresti togliere che senti
colpisco fuori cioè moria moriamo tutti
e due
frate mi6 in culo devi toglierti togliti
togliti va via se dico il fisco
schiacciamo entrambi togliti dalle che
vado a me che problemi tra veramente
nell'anno sto tizio ti aveva le facciamo
i power ranger frate segmento sei
esperto come faccio a sopravvivere in
questo momento come so come sopravvivo
ok a posto speriamo che tu ti sia
schianta lo guarda quindi se io dice zio
no zio cosa posso fare adesso potevi
fare qualcos'altro è bellissimo c'erano
cose stranissime st giorno sfida
controllata subito la faccio fido
ragazzi di don merda di don merda su non
valeva contenerlo 321 via le mappe
pagine così buio sono andate il via col
cazzo di vico ce la posso ancora fare
ragazzino figlio lo piglio che i tagli
dai dai dai dai
non credo l'ho preso una donna sono
velocissimo come facciamo ad api dietro
tipo le macchine tipo gran turismo come
riguardo dietro aiuto io non ci sono
danni in questa cosa sbaglio seminati
ragazzi non si capisce
non ci credo mai alzati veloce
no non è vero non è vero non è vero non
mi hanno superato sono dei debiti
cantavo non solo dipingiamo nonna sono
ripiglio chi le vittorie a tua madre si
dicono niente la gancia faccio
impossibile posso fare il salto che sia
un salto normale non è difficile
riuscirei anch'io che sono tutto o la
coordinazione di 1 posto morto dovendo
lo credo
lo vedo cacciare valerci per un secondo
da era fattibile la discesa serviva
proprio a sfoggiare le tue doti freeride
le mie doti in free live dio ma è legale
andare sui tetti delle case così ecco no
non lo è
buongiorno scusatemi se vi ho rovinato
tutto il tetto non era mia intenzione
giuro per buttarvi con la tuta alare di
qua se bene è svenuto ragazzi per
perfetto simpana qui non è che che si
appoggia vi si impara nelle cose
fantastico non vedi come sono bravo a
vari salti perché ho fatto volare un
drone è stato bellissimo regolamento
freestyle atene punti solo con i click
ok a me gli scritti e le donne grazie
bene si va beh quello è tutto skillato
tutto il playboy bravo prima intanto c'è
una [ __ ] guerra non te la toglie
nessuno allora ce la posso fare ed io ce
la faccio io risalti siano due cose che
non vanno bene insieme alla diavola
accordissimo velocissimo dai ok è uno
così e 2 bravo zio e tre
ok è molto più difficile di conto sempre
i ragazzi prefiggo medaglia d'argento e
cosa fare bene con la toro infatti un
caffè l'inter salto spiega le riprese da
nvidia
se sei vivo come quante vite ai frase
data la parola entrò nella finestra
vabbè ma basta basta stai calmo 66 morto
se non può essere vivo sei morto io
direi ragazzi che possiamo concludere
qui prima che mischianti sul serio e
figo e molto figo se non fosse che la
tuta l'area dove dovrebbero farcela
mentre solo quando puoi usarla perché se
non la usi per cagate non va bene spero
che i video vi sia piaciuto concluso che
ha bisogno di step cosa mi piace anche
ai vari social che come li aiuta nella
sezione senese avresti discreti di ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi
tutto storto